what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch from
heavy spoilers oh buddy Poe po that's
how the Brits say it oh
we're gonna watch the episode five
Easter egg breakdown that he's got going
for The Last of Us episode
Cinco Andrew Acres 7-Eleven showing his
arms today how are you I'm doing a lot
better than Jeffrey Pierce AKA Perry in
the last two uh episodes I have not run
into any bloaters lately so I'm good I'm
good
are you a dad
not yet not that I know of at least well
you got some jokes ready to go good
leave a like for Andrew's dad jokes
today
all righty we're all feeling confident
let's do this
so The Last of Us episode 5 is now out
and in this video we're gonna be
recapping the plot breaking down the
Easter eggs and also talking about the
game's similarities and differences
that's what I wanted to hear
survive endure and survive excuse me as
always this review won't contain
spoilers until the end of the video and
that'll be for people who've completed
both pots now we hop right after effects
last week which saw the introduction of
salmon Henry with your eyes last time
that they'd follow Joe and Ellie and
this is how they randomly ended up on
the same floor as they did in the
skyscraper this is confirmed in the
episode and Theory time right and the
entry centers around flashing out their
backstory along with Kathleen's on the
podcast for the show the creators stated
that she's like Madame dufage from A
Tale of Two Cities and she says very
Meek character who ends up becoming a
vengeful ringleader said on getting
revenge for the death of her family I
will say as much as I can have my back
and forth about the overall execution of
that character I feel it's really cool
that they decided to cast an actress who
played against type and I really feel
like she gave it a roll yeah no I mean I
I agree with you I know she was by far
your favorite character of the series so
far so yeah she was really fleshed out
but no I mean I I actually really
appreciated what they did with the
character in regards to I felt
empathetic towards you know her
motivation for getting revenge on her
brother even though he didn't want that
from her and I also did find you know it
interesting how you know she became that
in which she used to fight in regards to
fedra and now that's what she has become
like the oppressor I like that Lumen
more than you but you know I I totally
get where you're coming from and Greg I
don't understand why you're not agreeing
with me
because I'm a contrarian now last week
we missed that Tommy's voice actor
Jeffrey PS was playing the part of Perry
that sounds good you didn't miss that
people it's in the chamber eagle-eyed
viewers but there were two bullets in
there but that he need to pull the
trigger four times in order to shoot
Joel now in the game the pairs origin
wasn't as fleshed out as it is here in
that their accusing Hartford had been
abandoned by the military in fearing
that it could cause danger for Sam Henry
let him out of there with some other
survivors they traveled into Pittsburgh
searching for supplies and this is when
they were split from the group by a
bunch of writers they'd all agreed to
Rendezvous radar Tower which is when we
learn in the game that Sam was big and
the events played out much like what we
get at the end of the episode right
there's several nuts see a journey with
Sam and Henry lace throughout the entry
and we sort of get a compressed version
of it with us having the office building
Asian the sewers the sniper section that
you play through and the infected that
then swarmed the area Sam and Henry were
gray characters in the original game but
the episode very much elevates them
showing that they're willing to do dark
things in order order to survive there
are of course a reflection of Joe
lennelly with them both sharing the same
kinds of Dynamics well again like one of
the things that I love so much about
what they did with the actual episode
itself in terms of comparing to the game
was it did show a softer side so I think
actually making Sam Herring impaired
automatically forces Henry to become
more protective in that way and to be a
little bit softer because he has to
communicate even at a better level I
really appreciated all the choices all
around I think that's a nice way to
switch it up from what the game does
yeah for sure and obviously in the game
he's extremely protective of Sam but
just obviously albeit a lot more of a
stricter way so I I definitely enjoyed
the contrast and the difference that we
got in the show too now it's nice to
have two different versions of it I just
love you know what Paul was saying too
where they just gave the character so
much more depth rather than you know
they were from Hartford and then that
there you know they actually have a
history with the hunters that's what I
love about again biggest thing word we
use when we talk about this show I love
the expansion that they've done on so
many different characters I I agree that
time
now here we get the inner workings of
how they were part of Kathleen's team
and we learned that Henry sold out her
older brother to fedra this created an
uprising in the group overthrew Federer
which meant that Henry and Sam had a gun
hiding in order to escape them now we
start off the episode with the people
celebrating the disintegration of
Federer shut up into the sky like a
firework and the people then shout
freedom
again we have the We the People truck
and in case you missed our last video we
pointed out on that that it has roots in
the Constitution it's the first three
words that appear in it and it's very
much the people believing that they've
what is the Constitution
they're saying we are the people
appearing in that and Ellie's opening
scene that happens in the mirror either
way with all the uprisings come
Bloodshed and the celebrations are
juxtaposed by the dead Federal soldiers
that now line the street those that are
still living are brutally murdered and
the sigil for them is presented with a
fire beneath hitting at the crumbling of
this era I've always been a bit hit and
miss on the hate for Federer as they did
manage to stabilize America by creating
safe zones for the people episode 1
showed that though they kill the
infected without question they try to do
it in a nice way but as with all
authorities there are those that within
that can be corrupted in evil this was
showcased in episode 3 in which we know
that they murdered some evacuees in case
they became infected in the game's
counterpart Pittsburgh you learn that
the rebels did what they did here and
can piece enough things together to
learn why this was there's graffiti on
federal buildings complaining about how
people are being starved and when food
ran low obviously they kept the rations
for themselves now the trucks are on the
streets looking for collaborators and
over the 10 hours we can hear they'll
offer Fair trials
this is clearly [__] lie though as we
see Kathleen ordering several
collaborators to be executed in the next
scene there is something about the show
that I I do wonder if they are driving
the point home far enough because the
game really gives you a great insight
into why fedra is so messed up I'm
curious to know from like non-gamers if
the show really drives that point home
as well because a lot of this still
feels like introduction to them it still
feels lived in but at the same time I
feel like there's some context that
perhaps is not being fully realized just
yet on screen to really understand this
divide Rebels fedra and all that stuff
you know yeah for sure I mean I
definitely felt that a little more in
the game I do like the whole idea though
when it came to Kathleen's uh you know
the militia group taken over where they
were having Fair trials remind me a lot
of The Dark Knight Rises when Bane took
over uh Gotham City and then they use
the example of A Tale of Two Cities
which obviously a dark net Rises is very
heavily influenced on so I like seeing
the two parallels between the two that's
true good point I feel this is rapping
on real world politics and after the
second world war several Nazi
collaborated bears were hunted down
throughout Henry's called a rat and Jill
refuses to work with him initially
because he doesn't want to associate
with someone who [__] over his own
people to get a Lego with fedra in the
game he had a really tense moment where
they left you up squeak without a paddle
and I love how this uneasy Alliance also
carries over into the show we then see a
body being dragged behind a truck and
this has several knives in it this is
complete Overkill obviously I'm
potentially dumb for a reason to show
all those that were involved in taking
down Federer it's a simple Caesar was
killed he was stabbed 23 times and this
was done to show each of the
perpetrators had a hand in it and that
they were all in it together this
episode very much feels like the same
sort of thing with the rebels clearly
showing that they're willing to get
their hands dirty in order to overthrow
Pedra in a changeup from the game we
learned that Sam is deaf unless he talks
to Henry in sign language and has a
little magic board he can write on this
adds even more to just how vulnerable he
is and it clearly shows why Henry feels
like he has to protect his brother of
course title text is also done to mimic
how it appears in the game and the font
they use is exactly the same as it is
one of them gives up Dr Edelstein who we
learned last week was killed by Kathleen
or was it the next week anyway lots of
timing why me wibbly wobbly stuff and
she says that they'll be executed if
they don't give up Henry and Sam but
even when they do she still wants them
wiped out this really speaks to her
character and how she refuses to let her
brother's death go unavenged her right
hand man Perry asks why the pair is such
a priority as a city still in a state of
destabilization now we learn from Henry
that in fact it were driven underground
15 years ago but they've clearly been
awakened Once More by the revolution
happening on the surface Kathleen
doesn't care though and she's willing to
throw everything she has to make sure
the characters are caught as we learned
last week this involved overlooking a
hole in the ground teeming with infected
and this short-sightedness eventually
leads to her downfall and the end of her
people throughout the videos you've
talked about how the shoners have
constantly brought up the theme of Love
on the podcast and this something that's
definitely seen in Kathleen definitely
love can be good as in the case of Bill
and Frank but it also can have hugely
negative effects Kathleen loved her
brother and losing him is caused her to
hunt down all those involved in his
demise at the expense of others I love
hearing that that's how the creators of
the series are talking about it because
I've never really put that word love
into the context of the games part one
but especially part two the consequences
of what we do out of the act of love but
what's cool is that when you look at the
game you're like oh no that is exactly
what that is I've just never really used
the word love in the context of it all
and the consequences of love and I love
the point how he drove it home where you
know how love was used in regards to
Bill and Frank and then you know with
Melanie lynskey's uh character Kathleen
I was more thinking just in terms of
Revenge but obviously that Revenge comes
from her desire to avenge her brother
out of love again not going to spoilers
for future events I just love that it's
just so Last of Us in regards to you
know the the Revenge story and like what
it does it consumes Us in the darkness
you know how it just embroils your
entire mind and and desires and all that
that's what I appreciated about the
character and it just again just felt so
Last of Us now in overthrowing fedra
she's pretty much become the thing that
she saw to replace and there's a little
line that hints towards this burn the
bodies it's faster this is of course
what we saw gel doing the Federal in
episode one and it showcases how they're
both different wings of the same bird
it's possible that we actually saw the
collaborators bodies and if you cast
your mind back to episode 4 then you'll
remember there was a pile of them when
Jill and Ellie drove through the town
this moment pulled from the game and in
that Ellie said that they weren't
infected them giving up the doctor is
very on brand as well because they've
obviously been working with Federer and
are now betraying people in order to
survive another day and we see is Henry
and Sam end up meeting with the doctor
who hides them in an attic similar to
how Anne Frank and her family hit out
during the Holocaust last week Kathleen
discovered it abandon with empty tins of
food and in this entry we see what
happened during the time that they were
laying low we see Sam drawing his
character Super Sam and last week we got
a tease to this with him wearing his
orange face paint now I think one of the
running themes throughout the last of us
is how every character's childhood has
been Stripped Away because of the way
the world is humans could easily be here
I did but everyone fights amongst
themselves and those children don't
really get to live come the end of this
episode we now have three different
series and this comes in the form of
Sarah the child at the qz and of course
Sam Ellie and Nishi seems to be in
enjoying this world and though she's
making the most of it she's not really
seen as a kid either described as being
cargo she's just someone who can help
create a vaccine and there she isn't
really viewed as a person you know
what's funny about that line cargo
there's already enough similarities this
in the Mandalorian for Patriot Pascal
yeah yeah but he also refers to the baby
Yoda it's Cargo in the first season
that's why they specifically Craig Mason
came up with that line he's like I wanna
be a game is it in the game well where
he says she's cargo yeah it could let us
know in the comment moments I don't it's
not beautiful it's not coming back I
understand that but that I don't
remember that line from the game I'm not
recalling that line from the game but if
it is let us know I'm pretty confident
he says it I'm pretty confident he
doesn't so we're at a crosshairs here
you son of a [__] all right we're gonna
take the next 20 minutes to find this
moment
I've said this in other breakdowns but
children are our future and having so
many of them dying means there's no hope
for the human race wipe him out for 20
years but when the kids start dying it
won't be the infected that get us it'll
be the fact that there's no one to carry
on this species really poignant stuff
and we see 10 days going by with the
pair hiding out Sam had it so drilled
into his head that Federal of the enemy
that evenness is reflected in the
artwork with the drawings looking like
how the soldiers do in the gaming show
in another night to the game we see
Henry looking out the window and off in
the distance we can catch a yellow
Bridge
from Pittsburgh in the source of
material you and the group had to make
your way to assembly get out of the Town
eventually Joel and Ali ended up having
to jump off it and this happened after
they were chased by the Run truck
ah
God I love this game
[Music]
on the shore they were saved by Henry
and Sam who abandoned them when a ladder
broke during the chase with the truck at
this point you then pass through the
sewers which we'll talk more about in
just a bit when we get to The Hideout
section now Sam is worried that the
doctor isn't coming and as we know he
was captured by Kathleen he told Henry
to stay strong so that his brother
wouldn't worry but we can clearly see
that this is Weighing on him finally he
decides to accept the truth that he's
not coming back and the pair now to take
their chances in the city also worth
noting that Sam has a yellow hoodie on
at this point and this is the same thing
that he wore in the original game that's
the same hoodie is it really they look
so different to me oh the color Green's
a little lighter on the uh on the game
one but you think that's yellow I don't
know Paul
is that the same color does that look
yellow to you I could be wrong if it is
it's a very very light yellow
what kind of British [__] are you
playing at today buddy but you're dead
but they're both jackets
he's the expert and you're supposed to
be better than us
Henry gives him some orange face paint
which wasn't in the source material and
this is a nice little touch to add to
his character in the game you stop by a
toy store to hide out from the truck and
Sam wanted to take a robot Henry said no
because it would just take up space and
again it showed that kids couldn't be
kids in this world Sam what are you
doing nothing get rid of it
my backpack is practically empty what's
the world about taking stuff
it weighs like nothing rule what is it
we only take what we have to oh you took
it in the end and after making it to the
radio tower she did give it to Sam as a
little present that's why she died he
turned the next day but she kept this
tone her backpack as a reminder of him
Henry ends up checking the street and
this is when we see the action scene
from last week which gel crashed his
truck and had to shoot out with the
rebels I did go back and watch this
scene again to see if we could spot
Henry but unfortunately we we can't now
we do at the moment where Joe finishes
the shooting lowers his gun and looks in
that direction
that he doesn't actually see him oh
that's great oh man on this eventually
love that cartoon Man circle from last
week and a nice bit of attention to
detail you can also see that Henry has a
giant flashlight on his backpack and
this is in line with the one that he
also had in the game now that's accurate
Paul but it's on the wrong side right
there don't have to do this because she
unlocked the door he also goes straight
at the staircase and step on the glass
that Joel used to alert him however as
we discovered in episode 4 he's going
deaf in one ear and this is why he lay
on one side every time he went to sleep
also with noting that in episode 1 he
didn't hear Tess entering tying back
this whole deafness thing going on with
him wow what great card to do any
details man that's that's stuff that's
so easy to overlook it's good script
supervision or screenplay that is really
impressive because most movies and shows
would completely Overlook such a
specific specificity specific a specific
thing
I think you got it that one I nailed it
but I agree with you and I mean no yes I
agree with you I agree with you and I
think again because everyone knows I
love to play the comparison game but one
of the other films that always just
jumps to mind when you know doing that
kind of a scene from a different
perspective is Batman versus Superman
yes exactly that would be Superman and
Man of Steel so it just I got a lot of
flashbacks to that and again just really
really good job just showing us a
different perspective while still
keeping the same kind of new because and
that's not easy to do so and I
appreciated them you know really taking
their time and doing it the right way
you should watch the movie Vantage Point
I've never seen it well you're gonna see
the same story let us know 12 different
times let us know in the comments guys
if you want me to watch that on here are
the gameplay sings differently and after
you chase by the Run truck You Have To
Shimmy along a walkway and this is when
you jump through a window by Henry he
thinks you're right at but upon seeing
Ellie he realizes that you know with
them in camps where Federal were
overthrown they tend to either kill her
outcasts the kids because they just slow
the others down where are you from all
the way from Hartford I think Federer
makes the best decisions I heard some
bad stuff going on down there yeah the
military
Place probably looks like this by now
this is a major reason why Henry ended
up leaving Hartford as he knew Sam would
probably be murdered by the group that
took over the military's Place Jill
almost beat Henry to death which is when
Sam stepped in with a gun drawn similar
to what we get here Henry likely
realizes that they're in a similar
situation just an adult trying to escort
a kid through a hazardous City you know
what I've noticed one thing I wondered
if the show would do and they're not
doing it you carry a lot of [__] in the
game you got a backpack in the backpack
you got all the health kid you have the
molotov cocktails you have the bone
arrows you got the rifles and you can
only carry up to a certain amount which
is smart to make it more realistic yeah
but Pedro Pascal is never carrying
anything but like one gun you know
I wish she had a backpack a yellow
backpack now they end up sharing food
and this obviously means a lot in this
new world survivors have to be even more
careful because food was how the
cordyceps spread and thus given the
limited amount of food that they have
they have to be more tight with it now
we get a scene that sort of riffs on one
from the game in which they sit about
Sylvania area in the original Henry
ended up taking Jill and Ellie to their
Hideout which was located in an office
block across the city and the game they
of course want to make levels and
sections for you to fight through
whereas in a show they're not really
needed so you can just skip it and put
the scenes in the same location now you
run into one of these rooms and it had a
similar sort of layout to what we see in
the show the game had Henry's Hideout
located just above the gate that was in
front of the entrance to the bridge and
under the cover of Nightfall you ended
up launching your plan to pass it yeah
they do things differently and they look
over the city and point out the exits
Henry says he's never killed anyone and
though this is technically true we do
learn that he caused someone else's
death although it's all serious with
Henry and Joel salmonelli at least have
some fun Pikachu are reading the pun bug
to him and get some similar moments in
the show and game
all right ready ow the blueberry
it's been a while since that boy even
cracked a smile
D in the game Henry and Sam were
actually making their way to the
fireflies and Joel said it seems like
there's a lot of people putting their
stock on the fireflies these days yeah
maybe there's a reason for that
you don't know where they are you're
just going to drag him across the
country to find him this was ironic as
well because he he was of course making
his way across the country Without
Really knowing where they were either
anyway Henry draws up a map of the city
and tells them that they're going to be
heading through the maintenance tunnels
Henry wants Jill to help him navigate
these as they could still have infected
in them Henry actually calls a click or
a clicker and you know what it's nice to
see a live-action thing not embarrassed
by the terminology that they use in the
games he says that someone he knew from
federal that was the first time they
said it the possibility that some might
be down there and he and Sam won't be
strong enough to deal with them only he
knows is though and the theory though is
that Kathleen won't follow them because
of the danger there could be now they
head into another building and this
resembles the one that you first move
into when you storm the gate out well
they're here they head underground
really going on we get this line that's
kind of a pessimistic
which is another two it's just you and
your daughter we're not related we're
more like um I promise someone I'd look
after yeah
yeah I can appreciate that now as you
mentioned earlier this is basically
combining the suic section of the game
so that it's part of Kansas as we stated
Joe and Ali jumped off the bridge and
this is when they were pulled ashore by
Henry and Sam you found about washed up
along with some notes and a home in the
sewer that was once teeming with people
children were of course killed by the
bandits unless they fled here with their
parents to try and carve out a life I
was gonna say that that's something like
this might have happened here but Joel
says that lots of people went
underground on outbreak day it's
possible that people ended up lying low
here and then when the infected were
pushed in the ground they wiped them out
because they'd bottle themselves in
yikes now the entrance to this oh boy
and this is something that also pops up
in the game when you first entered the
sewers anyway when they enter the room
there are several things here that are
ripped right out of the source pictures
now against the back wall we can see a
girl drawn onto it and there was an
optional cut scene in which Ali played
football against Sam yes I'm saying
football again I'm not saying soccer
I've had enough for you guys
no you can probably hear I'm very ill at
the moment most of your audience is us
it's much appreciated and I hope it
doesn't ruin the video for you like it's
ruined my life making these videos for
you I hate you so this plays on the
scene similar to what we get here
yeah
it even sounds just like the game
uh calm down
I remember Sam asks Henry about the kick
and he's like all right keep it down
buddy
did you see that
I'm down buddy okay
Davey you were right about that line I
missed closer to Sarah because Sarah
also played soccer when she was a child
hey said sucker for you guys out there
you suckers hey no we do get a little
subtle gesture by Joel here and he looks
down at his watch after looking at Ellie
now that's a great catch completely
fluid that you can catch that that flew
over my head and I to be honest because
most you know because it was so sad
Hollywood [__] would do like a
close-up on Joel and really draw
attention to it you know yeah but that's
just such a subtle way of capturing the
character Nuance yeah for sure and also
we got to see another moment of that
right after Tess had been bitten in the
museum you know we see the scene
straight out of the game with the plank
yeah we saw after uh Joel and Ellie had
had an interaction he kind of looked at
his watch which you pointed out when
that happened during our reaction and I
like to play the comparison game too and
soccer reminds me of bended Like Beckham
don't you mean football
oh yeah no this reminds me of the
replacement starring Keanu Reeves love
that love love love that the director of
Iron Man this is Samia Sarah of course
gave him and looking at the watch
reminds him of the daughter he lost he
also did this in episode 2 and as we
know it doesn't work so it's not like
he's using it to read what the time is
it just shows how much Ellie reminds him
of Sarah and moments like this say so
much with so little there's a slide
which I think was in the game and also a
big sign that says house rules when you
made your way through the underground
you could spot this and the rules on
both are identical why would I read any
of that [__] again doors are locked ask
for password if you don't know the
visitor no shouting in noisy play run to
hiding spot when you hear the alarm now
in the game you accidentally set off one
of the alarms the infected they had
bottles inside a box on the end of a
rope and setting this off showed them
where you were you also see blue barrels
with tubes popping at the top of them
and we learn in the game that these were
used to collect rain so that they had to
supply water now in what's my favorite
Easter egg from the show so far you see
a child's drawing with Danny and ish on
the wall this is identical to how it
appears in the game also when traversing
the suit let's see the color palette is
a little different on this I mean the
pic the picture yeah it looks completely
and but if yeah he actually has an
extensive backstory that you discover
through notes that you're spying
throughout the sewers yeah which is a
great support in the game and he's based
on the character issue with Williams
from the 1949 book earthbite in that
there was also a pandemic and the
character ended up establishing a
community of survivors like what we see
here he was meant to look like Ishmael
from Moby Dick and this idea of being a
sailor carried across to the game wow
did you ever discover those letters I
never I don't I wonder if I did I just
don't remember I I did and I'm gonna be
honest they were interesting but like
when I'm playing a video game and I have
to read a bunch of stuff even if it's
interesting sometimes I zone out I'm
like I'm just gonna keep playing there
were times where I would read full-on
letters I didn't when it came to Danny
Anisha that whole thing in regards to
sewer I didn't go into the whole thing
but I collected all the notes but I
didn't read it I'd get like a quarter
into it I'm like this is good but I want
to play right now I want to shoot I want
to shoot some some Infected right now I
get you I mean that's why I can't do
less places when I play a game sometimes
I put it on pause to read a chapter of a
Stephen King novel ah gets in the way of
the momentum I mean if you're gonna
pause it you got to do a Stephen King
novel so that I think you're good after
the outbreak he went to sea for several
months but eventually he had to go to
show and he landed near Pittsburgh this
is the boat that you encounter after the
bridge and it's here that you discover
the first part of his story we learned
that he ended up going into the Suez and
it's here oh yes it's coming back ended
up going into the suburbs behind them
which is where he came across a family
of other survivors though they initially
just traded supplies ish ended up
inviting them down into the sewers which
is where they built the community
unfortunately someone didn't follow the
rules and they left the door unlocked
which is when the infected broke in by
the time he got there it was completely
abandoned and we was a horrifying event
for those stuck inside one of the notes
said that the teachers barricaded
themselves in a nursery with some of the
other children and and had to well do
what happened at the end of the Mist you
know that that's the only part I've seen
that I could say life's an ish and then
you die hey
now ish actually made it and he and some
of the other survivors fled into the
suburbs which is the next area the
characters go into in both the show and
game I was wondering if this old guy was
actually him but let's hope not now on
top of this we also see that very wild
Starlight comic these were collectibles
in the game and they told the story of
Dr Daniela star who could travel faster
than light the cover here is pulled
directly from the PlayStation counterpod
and this is the aggression issue brought
across from it in the second game the
comics and Beyond just being comics and
you also collected trading cards of
characters from the story this included
Dr upman Who was based on your druckman
yeah aka the game and series Creator Ali
also says his catchphrase
Edge of the universe
and back
to the edge of the universe and back
endure and survive excuse me
endure
and survive and you know I really enjoy
these moments with them just getting to
be kids as it's something that we
haven't really seen that much in the
show
it's because you're a Dad we're not dads
so we don't give a [__] about their
bonding am I right buddy I didn't care
at all I was not emotionally invested in
those two characters at all and in fact
when what happens to Sam happens I I
didn't give any two craps at all I was
about to applaud when it happened and
then I had to restrain myself because I
thought people might misinterpret this
nah nobody misinterprets anything on the
internet
no I really like that stuff too yeah it
knows it was good it was good and I seen
the different deliveries yeah yeah and
two like like I mentioned in in our uh
reaction video uh me personally I felt
in the game he had a little bit of a
crush on Ellie in regards to he changed
the his age and and I like the dynamic
in this a little bit more personally
just where again there being more kids
and he looks up to her like kind of an
older sister and I was definitely
emotionally invested in them for sure in
the game but and it was a little bit
deeper and more fleshed out here for me
oh yeah no if it even adds a protective
quality for Ellie in that moment now
when they take the comic out the back we
can also catch the book to Old potatoes
and me this sentence around a girl whose
parents are going through divorce and
she builds a relationship with her
father whilst the pair grow new potatoes
from some old ones initially the girl
finds the potatoes in the cupboard and
she thinks they're gross but over the
book she learns and New Opportunities
from then they can grow something new
and this is similar to her parents
divorce enabling her to have a different
but new type of life now this is very
much reflected in jail who are making
something new in this world that's
falling apart around them now it's at
this point they decide to wait a couple
of hours and then they decide to make
their move this causes a bit of time
difference from The Source material as
you were riding the suburbs and played
at the sniper section during the middle
of the day yeah though it happens at
night and this is because you don't
really travel through the sewers now
Joel and Henry took it out and he
apologized
however Henry reveals what really
happened with Kathleen's brother the way
he describes him he sounds like the
second coming of Mr Beast and I bet he's
the kind of person who would always like
comment and subscribe even if the host's
voice didn't sound as good as it
normally does anyway Henry says that Sam
got sick with leukemia and thus he had
to work with Federer to get a special
drug that was in short supply little did
Henry know this pushed the resistance
over the edge and we ended up getting
what we see in Kansas City Henry gave up
someone amazing that could have led the
people into a new world for the life of
someone he loved and we'll talk later on
about how this thematically repeats
through the show and that's super
spoiler section just I wonder where
that's going to go Jill was a father and
similar him he'd of course do anything
to protect the ones he loves protect
credit Kathleen and we see her in the
room that she grew up in with her
brother this is a donut ornaments and
also kids playing football again tying
back this photo of Sarah check the
Analytics
our biggest audience is America who are
planes who are playing soccer now Perry
returns with some bad news chill and
Henry are still at large son of them in
the city Kathleen reveals that her
brother's name was Michael and it's
possible that he was a firefly due to a
dog tag that we find with that name on
in the game might be a reach here but
Michael likely did there was a different
way of life and this is of course
something that the fireflies also do the
idea of him giving people optimism is
represented in Kathleen who tells a
story about how they used to change
their rooms using their imagination
he was so beautiful
it was constant gunfire screaming and
bombing in the town but in this room
they managed to make it feel like a safe
place Michael likely did that to
everyone growing up and it really makes
you question whether Sam's life was
worth his obviously you don't want to be
killing kids but the Carnage it's caused
by handing him over shows that even
things done with the best intentions
have their own costs as Michael
character sounds like quite a compelling
fella what would you think about us
getting a spin-off seeing who Michael is
just doing good deeds letting people use
their imagination who's the guy who
wrote Peter Pan the one that Johnny Depp
played uh Finding Neverland you mean I
mean yeah he played him in Finding
Neverland no he played JM Berry didn't
play Peter Pan he played I said who's
the guy who wrote Peter Pan Jamberry
yeah oh my God Andrew you're ruining our
back and forth uh so I had a great thing
going here and then you ruined it why
did I even pause it you said who's the
guy who played Peter Pan I said who's
the guy who wrote Peter Pan he said Play
I said Johnny Depp played him
I don't know now
who's the guy who wrote Peter Pan the
one that Johnny Depp played
uh Finding Neverland you mean but where
were you going with this I forgot
it stays in the video now Kathleen said
she visited her brother in jail and he
told her to forgive last week when
talking to the doctor she said that the
room they were in could be the one
Michael was tortured at and again
because of this she can't forgive now we
jump backwards sounds like John the
Baptist them making their way into a
bank car park this could be riffing on a
secret location in the second game in
which he traveled West like bank and got
a shot Canali I like the game once you
hit the Main Street you peppered by a
sniper they have the layout exactly the
same with them
at the end of the road similar to what
happens here Joe uses cars for cover and
he makes his way down to it before you
take out the Gunner
Henry running up in the game the pair
make a break for it here but they're
almost shot when trying to escape I
really do wish in the show they made it
harder for him to get to the sniper I
really feel like I do I do agree with
that point I love the episode but I do
agree with that point for sure I think
even if I didn't play the game I would
have been like oh what a cool setup for
a really tense I I love that kind of
action scene really sniper up there and
you gotta like find your way around to
get to the sniper it did feel kind of
easy the the way he got around and just
got up there whereas in again not going
into like if you were in a game or if
you were but in the game it was a lot
more difficult yeah there were other
guys charging at you as well but just if
you like got a little around a corner
that sniper was gonna hit you like it
was hard and it's a sniper so it makes
fun and he's an old ass sniper too so
you know he's good he's gotta he's got
200 years of experience that's my first
the game also had riders in houses along
the street whereas this guy is just by
himself he's much older than his game
counterpart and it explains why Joel's
able to get the drop on him so easily
you're the cgo looking out to a river
with a bridge on it which is riffing on
the one from the Pittsburgh chapter that
you had to get to I was also wondering
whether Joel was thinking should I make
a break for it
um I don't think he is but yeah let me
know below if you had that
interpretation now in the game tonight I
always wondered why this guy didn't move
when he saw you coming up the street his
position is clearly given away but here
we see that he's been working with
Kathleen and thus he didn't really want
to vacate this spot
he was deliberately trying to hold them
in place so goodbye Kathleen in her
group time to arrive and they then show
up at this point this whole scene riffs
on the game quite a lot and in it Jill
takes a sniper and he watches the Run
truck arrives in the show we see the
battering ram on the front being used to
clear out cars and this is something
Joel touched upon last week when talking
about how the roads were cleared
must have been some truck yeah they used
to stick big ass clouds on them and
clear the roads for their tanks and such
a rebel popping at the top that was
throwing molotovs this caused him to
drop it in the car which said it alight
and this then crashed into one of the
houses I do gotta give Andrew credit he
did say foreshadowing on that moment in
the reaction for episode four but I cut
it out because I was like is someone
gonna give us a lot of crap for spoiling
it even though I don't think it's that
big of a deal it's a super shot every
contact I appreciate you saving me the
trouble of being accused of spoiling so
Craig thank you so much and for the
recognition you're you're the best
friend anyone could ever ask for
I know
right back at me
you're doing good thanks
bro now the infected sprung out and this
is how Sam got bit you ended up playing
to the towers in fact you can even see
his limping there you never know pretty
much how the sequence ended here they
changed things up where the truck driver
still crashing but to make things even
more tense we get Kathleen holding
everyone except y'all at gunpoint she
says [__] them kids and justifies
murdering them by saying kid style all
the time she sees Sam as being someone
who should have been left to his fate
instead of costing her her brother
leftover bait still has a hand to play
Zen unleashing a terrifying horde of
infected we see one set on fire and this
is a similar effect to what would happen
when he hit one with a molotov in the
game because Joel couldn't get hit
you're kind of just sniping away and
having a bit of a laugh now at this
point we see a big bad blowout who is
first teased at all the way back in
episode two so there aren't super
infected they just build fungus spores
on you [__] I hope not you could also
hear the creature growling into the
cracks in the floor last week and this
makes a really big entrance in the game
he actually faced off against them
during build section but I'm kind of
glad we got the greatest love story ever
told instead and they kept his arrival
for this scene I would have preferred it
if right before when Frank's like take
me to the bedroom yeah and then as he's
Wheeling him in
then a bloater just burst through and
just tears them apart I mean it
definitely would have been subversion of
expectations so if you would have seen a
comment yeah from that perspective it
would have added you know a different
flavor to the episode you know we'll
never know now I think they really
missed a great opportunity there
yeah they did they definitely did but uh
no I I I love the what they did here
with the uh the bloater like actually
seeing it on the big screen I just I I
love what they did with this and then
showing the power level too and just
again the difference of what you saw
from the game in here in the game I mean
you definitely get a horde coming out at
you but this is like on a different less
scale that we've never ever seen and to
see it in live action the way it was
meticulously shot and how they were all
coming out it just it was really
freaking scary and awesome at the same
time so like the fire illumination for
the night it's great that's true it's
like hell has risen yeah in the game it
was a one-hit kill if they grabbed you
stick their fingers in your mouth and
rip your head apart Perry gets killed in
the exact same way and seeing this
happen in the background I was like that
they went there
child clickers don't appear in the game
and I'm guessing that this was used
because it later kills Kathleen and she
was very much saying how kids didn't
really matter uh yes that completely
flew over my head I didn't even put that
two and two together oh the I ironic I
was more caught up in ah you know
Catherine if you just let them go you
might have survived there is an ironic
sense of death there not only that but
you were also thinking too like I can't
stand Kathleen so you were just so mired
yeah
the simplest iconic uh line of
foreshadowing just went over your head
and I was just so mired by your hate
that I missed it so this is all my fault
I do I blame you for most things even
when you're not around it's true guys he
does but usually it is my fault so I
actually take it if John's not around
it's gonna be you
or God she's got to look for something
Henry and Sam are pinned down like what
happens in the original work but Ellie
saves them and they make a run for it
she uses a knife and this is also a
tactic that she bust out in the source
material as we said Kathleen gets killed
and in an eerie final shot we see the
infected running towards the city
they'll likely destroy the resistance as
they lie asleep in their beds and I
doubt that even Dorothy would want to
get back to Kansas eh now in the game
Henry said Pittsburgh it's skeleton
Crews at night which is why they opted
to move out then and I can imagine it
being a similar thing set up in Kansas
this means it's gonna be a very
short-lived Revolution and because
Kathleen couldn't forgive it's led to
this downfall now the group make it to a
motel and we see Henry is really shaken
up by it but the kids have got to it
okay anyway the conversation in the game
is a lot more light-hearted I do love
how the adults seem a lot more shaken up
and the kids are like yeah we're good
for our Comics just another day because
they're used to growing up in lifestyle
where this is still something that's
that interrupted their life yeah for
sure and also obviously the difference
here with Henry in regards to the game
in this I mean in the game he had killed
a lot more people and we also we
witnessed him killing people when we're
trying to escape out of Pittsburgh
obviously the description we get of him
in the show is the only person that he's
killed technically was by way of proxy I
mean did we it could be wrong did we
witness Sam Actually killing during that
battle or was it mostly just running
away and Joel was saving them I know
Henry got a few kills in but there was
so much chaos happening it's hard for me
to remember but obviously we saw that
Ellie got a few kills so she's used kind
of used to doing it but to me it just it
captured the whole moment of like I've
never experienced something like this
and just like getting that shock of your
first kill so that's how I interpreted
it and that's where I thought this actor
did a phenomenal job of like showing
that Terror of like getting through
something so crazy and and the
adrenaline rush that comes with you know
killing for the first time
there is an adrenaline rush when you do
it oh yeah no you've told me you've told
me many times I know I can't stop
don't look in Greg's backyard guys
you can come by
it's better than keeping it inside it
starts to smell anyway the conversation
in the game is a lot more light-hearted
with them talking about Tommy before
moving on to the group not showing up
it's Tommy's birthday that's all he
wanted to do Harley Davidson yeah I went
to Harleys and drive cross country oh
man
I could die happy if I could just ride
one around the block
what was it like
it was good it was real good
good keep can you believe this guy
detail come on man give me details
describe it you know what you two
deserve a little privacy Ellie this
isn't just any regular motorcycle okay
you get on that bad boy you feel that
engine nothing like it oh yeah how would
you know
seen it in my dreams
okay
[Laughter]
I don't think anyone from my group is
gonna show up in the show gel invites
Henry and Sam to join them on their
quest to find Tommy and this will give
them a new Fresh Start the game also
changes things slightly and with Sam he
was clearly wrestling with what would
happen now that he'd been bit
is everything all right
everything's fine
well
the good night
how's it that you're never scared
who says that I'm not
what are you scared of
[Music]
scorpions are pretty creepy
scorpions
um
being by myself
scared of ending up alone
what about you
those things out there
what if the people are still inside
what if they're trapped in there without
any control of their body
and all that
I'm scared of that happening to me
okay
first of all we're Team now okay we're
gonna help each other out and second
they might still look like people but
that person is not in there anymore I'm
in the show Ali and Sam said about
reading comics and he eventually asks if
she's ever scared we gotta scene that
riffs on the game with the answers being
written down and shed between the two
whereas in that it was a conversation
like the previous cutscene Ali says
she's scared of being alone and this
plays into a character moment that we'll
talk about in the spoilers section Sam
also asks if it's still you inside when
you turn and he then shows her his bite
this is unlike the game is in that he
keeps it to himself however he does pull
up his trouser lag to reveal it like
what we get here Alicia was just how
naive she is because she believes her
blood can kirim and it very much plays
in her believing that she is the vaccine
she sort of has a Maasai complex and
believes she can heal the sick but this
of course doesn't end up working out
it's very much a kind of I don't know
kids view of Science and he gives Ali
another cruel dose of reality in the
harsh light of day in the game Henry
gelinelli sleep in the same room and
when she went to get him up she
discovered he'd been turned we see Sam's
back first like what we get here but
Ellie spent the entire night with him
bow the scenes play out in a similar way
and I'll drop them side by side so you
can see the differences as well as what
they kept
that smells good it does good morning
where's Sam
I let him sleep in for once
oh
well if you wanted to join us you can go
wake his ass up
the one time you lose
Sam I interrupt this side by side to say
that is some interesting parenting to
let your two teenagers sleep in the same
room alone
very true I mean now be it one was eight
and fourteen but yeah that's a good
point I mean you gotta post-apocalyptic
world or not you gotta have a little
better parenting skills there should be
some boundaries
all right see boundaries
the little things great
damn what the hell
[__] he's turning
that's my [__] brother
screw it
come on
[__]
you're right
oh my God see
oh no
Sam
Henry
hello stay here Henry
[Music]
I'm gonna get that gun from you okay
oh okay okay easy is it sure
this is nobody's fault Henry
it's not gonna [__] Henry
Henry no
oh my God
let me know
they both end in Sam and Henry's death
and that closes out another entry with
some big characters passing away I think
every episode I probably didn't have
music in the live action big death in it
and the first had Sarah Tess was in the
second Bill and Frank in three and now
Henry and Sam yeah it actually hurts
more than it did in the game because we
know that Henry gave up Michael in order
to save his brother he still had to kill
him though once he became infected and
it shows how dark and Bleak this world
actually is even if you save someone
this can still be taken away from you
and this all can happen at a moment's
notice outside they bury the yellow car
smacked you there me outside they bury
their bodies and now he creates a
makeshift gravestone using Sam's Board
in the game you actually came across a
child's grave and it's just as
depressing as it is here
should be smaller I forgot to leave that
stupid robot on his grave what should I
do with it I mean what I want to talk
about it no why not how many times do we
need to go over this
things happen and we move on it's just
that's enough
all right
I'm sorry
Ellie of course forgot to put the robot
toy on it but here she remembers to drop
Sam's Board she writes I'm sorry and
clearly deals with the survivor's Guild
of the situation Ellie is still alive
from her bite whereas Sam isn't and her
actions the night before potentially
also cost Henry's life to pass it out
and in the moment that riffs on their
Silhouettes and the credits we close out
with them journeying out west now for
the next part of the video we're gonna
be talking about game spoilers and
things that will be let's go story for
you if you haven't played them what the
[__] is wrong with you why the [__]
haven't you played the last of us we're
five episodes Stephen you started
anyway the two characters that I think
reflect Joel here are Kathleen and Henry
who both end up doing bad things out of
love Kathleen's love ends up turning her
into a bitter and vengeful person and in
the end this Dooms her entire town this
could be similar how Joel was affected
by Sarah and his attack at the end Dooms
Humanity because we don't get a vaccine
I know people kind of go back and forth
over whether the vaccine would have
worked or not but the second game done
is kind of spell out that there was a
pretty big chance now how is Henry like
Joel well Henry's actions to save Sam
ended up leading to Michael's death he
put the life of the person he loved
bubble else and this could be reflected
in Joel's actions to kill the fireflies
at the end that's more of a well they're
both pretty tenuous but I thought I'd
just bring it up here in case they end
up going that route in the series I'm
pretty sure they will at this point
because so far it's been almost
identical to the game but the bill and
Frank episode and the odd change here
and there it's also possible that
Kathleen is somewhat of a mirror of Abby
as both are avenging someone that was
murdered at which eventually leads to
losing a lot definitely saying she's
scared of adding up alone could possibly
play into the next episode which will
potentially take them to Jackson so I
feel like they've been planting these
seeds for the last of us too we are
talking full spoilers here I feel like
they've been planting these thematic
seeds that are very much mirroring so
much of the last of us too to prepare us
for the inevitable when they beat Joel's
head in yeah via a new protagonist in
the name of Abby and I'm gonna eat it up
oh you're talking about where she gets a
Joel in one right yeah I love it Andrew
yeah I can't wait for Pedro to get his
head back yes I just want to see a
reaction from grogu when he's uh when he
sees that you know that's the oh yeah
for them to cut it together in regards
to spoilers we talked off camera about
this after episode five when you know
obviously that Ellie has the Messiah
complex and she tries to do the blood
transfusion in regards to sandwich I
love that change like I really deeply
appreciate I actually like that a little
bit better than the game personally
obviously we don't know what a person
goes through in their mind when the turn
happens but just knowing that someone
knew about it and he wasn't like alone
in the moment I just it felt a lot
deeper and more personal to him from
that perspective and that Ellie did try
to save him whereas in the game he
really went by himself alone like he
like he felt like he had nobody in
regards to when he was turning by
himself also we talked about off camera
that when she tries to give him the the
blood transfusion we talked about the
importance of Dr Jerry Anderson Abby's
uh Abby's father and like Okay so this
character obviously as described in the
second game is so important because you
can't just use Ellie's blood like you
need someone who knows what to do with
the blood in order to create this
vaccines I like how again you're talking
about laying down seeds so like yeah
this just showed the importance of
Abby's father when you can't just use
Ellie's blood to just save someone like
you need a doctor who knows what they're
doing they're laying the foundation for
Abby's father so
you keep saying we talk off camera but
sometimes sometimes sometimes we'll do
the board like that Sam had and we'll
just communicate with each other but
sometimes we do talk off camera you know
but Greg has to give me permission he
said did I tell you you could talk no
you're not talking to me I've got a big
channel here my name's Craig Alba you're
just nobody I've instructed my assistant
to make sure you communicate to her via
email I think I lost that email I'm
gonna need to get it again
that explains why things have gone to
[__] around here yeah I haven't seen the
trailers yet as we make these videos
before they release but I'm guessing
that the next entry centers around them
relying with Tommy in the game jail
pretty much wanted to fleece Ellie off
to him and she ended up running away for
a bit chilling Tommy headed out to get
her which is when they came across right
as but eventually they managed to catch
back up to her which prom promised to
take care of the fireflies himself and I
can't imagine that basically being the
plot of the next entry now as for my
thoughts on this one I did think it was
a solid way to build up last week and
even though I knew it was coming the
Henry and Sam deaths were still
devastating just leaves that feeling of
hopelessness that the last of us is
built upon and you can see how the
characters become completely jaded and
self-centered no one's really gonna look
after them so they have to look after
themselves unless they push themselves
into this one track mind based solely on
Surviving this is what Joel had but
Alias made him realize that there's more
to life than just making it through the
day-to-day bill of course discover this
and it's very much layered throughout
the entire season I think Henry and Sam
was spot on as well as you couldn't
really ask for more accurate adaptations
of them yeah I know Sam wasn't deaf but
he played the part of a kid trying to be
a kid in the apocalypse really well and
it did provide a devastating ending that
I think a lot of people are going to be
shocked by I actually found myself
almost being like Joe at this point and
as the guys just put Tessa's death at
the back of his mind and kept going and
that's what I do once they ended up dead
these characters they have big passings
and I'm I'm like well just gotta keep
surviving I guess can't stand around it
really shows how well crafted that the
series is but I do have some faults with
it I kind of felt like Melanie lynskey
was a bit weak thank you I don't know
why anyone would really follow her I get
the whole brother dying put her in
charge but she didn't really come across
someone that could command others just a
nitpick for the episode and yeah if you
disagree that's fine I disagree let me
know below now I hope you enjoyed the
breakdown either way and obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below well yeah man
good [__] learning a lot that's probably
my favorite one you've done so far out
of the breakdowns here man I think you
did a good job I will not message you
that personally but I will say it here
on camera to look like a better human
being and also too I do want to add to
one thing you did mention in regards to
Jesus sorry I know we haven't talked in
a lot in this video but I did like the
the point that you made whereas in the
video game I made a point okay let's
hear it that's here where Henry when he
shoots himself uh we hear the the game
music by Gustavo santalaya in the
background which was I still thought
that music was great but not having the
music in the background in the show it
just you feel the gravity and the weight
of the situation a little bit more it's
a little more gut-wrenching without this
or the even though the score was
fantastic in the game it's a little more
gut-wrenching for me just not because
again you feel the weight of the
situation and how daunting of what he
had to go through to save his brother
and then having to do that like I didn't
even think about that in the moment like
oh there's no background score where
there was in the game so thank you for
pointing that out
Lance door Lance would be the perfect
person to survive an apocalypse with one
you know what I'm just gonna I always
had this whole thing about you being a
firefighter because he's a firefighter
and that would be like a great person to
surviving definitely but here's the
other thing you gotta you got you got
yourself a a wife and a kid in
Valentine's Day is coming up so uh I'm
gonna redirect the shout out to be like
well there's going to be a fire it's
going to be put out
this coming Tuesday at the Canadian
border
where you're from I should have gone
with the apocalypse one I think I had
more to do with that I definitely could
have Rift more on that
then on uh
you doing fun stuff with your with your
wife
smoking hot wife my God
yeah she's a looker that one
yeah you're lucky son of a [__]
I hate you
but Lance I'm really happy you're part
of our patreon page dude
[Music]